et social d imad à des histoires de de
parler de sexualité dire des bêtises tu
fais les footballeurs ont-ils raison
d'exposer leurs richesses et qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette chronique
beinheim bain sans exposer leurs
richesses ils vont pas et sans exhiber
leurs richesses ils vont pas se cacher
de gagner de l'argent
ce serait ridicule et on les pointerait
du doigt si on disait et hypocrites ils
gagnent des millions ils vont pas venir
habillés avec des petites des débuts des
petites marques et on dirait mais qu'est
ce que tu vas tu nous prends pour des
imbéciles
donc voilà on leur demande pas non plus
de d'exhiber mais ils vont pas se cacher
ils n'ont pas volé cet argent
mathieu de lanvollon là n'est pas du
tout d'accord là dessus des antiquaires
à redon non millar il a raison tous les
six mois par douala le vainqueur dans
les gares aux cette année a gagné 2
millions et demi d'euros
il en a fait ce qu il en a rien le
football par définition c'est
systématiquement l'indécence c'est quand
l'argent remplace éducation je n'ai
jamais vu un autre port où c'est un
combat de mma c'est d'une bagnole à
millions d'euros et je te mets des
jantes en or et j'arrivais de déchets
mais et je bouffe de l'avion en avec de
l'or dessus et tout ça c'est le c de la
vulgarité poussé à son comble on peut
gagner de l'argent bien sûr qu'il le
mérite
mais à ce point être aussi indécent le
cracher à la gueule des gens avec ou
sans terminal pardon de vous le dire de
ce café bfm
au contraire c'est très bien c'est
montrer que ces gens je suis allé dans
ok y'a des sports organisera encore une
salle de tennis de roland garros les
deux millions et demi ça fait des ondes
soit 8 kilos gagnés ctri 30 millions
d'euros vous avez déjà vu nadal arrivé
comme ça et claqué son je sais que vous
aimez vous aimez les footeux oui c'est
bien moi excusez faire croître sur ce
que vous pensez le trophée de la
descente la plus totale
c'est une honte matthew les doigts de
claquer de l'argent comme ça avec autant
de fierté
maintenant on va voir s'ils ne la
regagner leur poids ne suis pas d'accord
héros et vous avez droit alors s'il vous
plaît s'il ne se blesse et minul plus
populaire mais c'est normal que quand tu
réussis que tu viens du plus bas c'est
que tu arrives au plus haut et plus
enviés d'exposer ma façon tu as ta
réussite que quand les pilotes de
formule 1 a mené par des milliardaires
qui paient la moitié du budget communal
ou la tv devant tu peux te la jouer cool
façon tu peux t'aider dans avec une
cuillère en argent dans la bouche quand
tu fais une bête a réussi c'est normal
temps vide est fière d'eux
montrer qu'on n'arrive déjà pas à voir à
11h argent ils en font gagner beaucoup
ils le montrent hiller qui fait
vêtements c'est des jeunes voilà il ya
des gens décédés selon qui les fringues
les marques c'est comme ça alors on va
on va voir ce qu'on pense d'isabelle et
est ce qu'on pensait que des meilleurs
systèmes mathieu va répondre encore les
jours des toutous la réputation d'être
bing bling comme le dit matthieu
delormeau le montant de leur salaire le
montant de leurs transferts le montant
de leurs contrats avec leurs sponsors
sont rendus publics ils sont simplement
cohérent avec ce que l'on sait de leur
train de vie on va pas faire partie de
ceux qui reprochent à des gens de
réussir et de cannes et de l'agent
l'aurore pour ce flambeau qui flambent
qui flambent qu'ils ne sachent pas
s'habiller ils ne savent pas ce qu'est
que tu les trouves vulgaire ils sont
vulgaires qui n'est pas acheter le bon
pull balanciaga que son dernier avec le
bon grands talons chanel c'est un autre
problème ça c'est une question de style
et de goût mais ils ont droit d'avoir le
bouquet d'aller vous êtes kemar en syrie
green ce qu'ils veulent mais quand quand
c'est un animateur quand c'est n'importe
qui quand et n'importe quelle autre
personne
même quand ça à bernard arnault ou
quelqu'un qui fait vivre ou même bolloré
qui baisse d'impôts en france et qui
fait vivre 50000 personnes
quand tu ne cois salaires par il en
prendre plein la gueule mais comme c'est
un footballeur parce qu'il a mis un but
pour la france ou de tout pardonner
voiture que j'avais vu acheté je sais
plus si c'était un ribéry pardon si
c'est pas lui c'est l'été mais oui c'est
votre ami me dit c'est pareil
aujourd'hui c'est drucker et benzema
tout le monde et benzema c'était à nice
elle c'est une biquette un bureau c'est
un million cent mille euros et je te l'a
montré elle en or et tout ça qu'ils le
fassent mais il fait rêver les jeunes
ménages en délire il ya un truc que vous
devez comprendre faire rêver les jeunes
il faut comprendre qu encore une fois
faire rêver les jeunes c'est pas grave
est strict et l'exposer en permanence
c'est être un petit peu éduqués faire un
métier qu'on aime c'est pour vous avez
je faisais du vélo union le ver je pense
que mathieu fauves retourner le problème
parce qu'en fait je dois pas le jeu
blanc non non c'est à dire que c'est ce
que ce qu'on faut comprendre c'est le
public est demandeur de sartre et ça
c'est pas les footeux qui provoquent ils
font que répondre à la demande d'un
public les publics mc nabb des blessés
le film et le public aime ça le public
rachète les mêmes vêtements que parce
que c'est une demande du public et les
marques utilisent d'ailleurs les
footballeurs comme toutes les stars la
baisse des marchés
les vraies demandes du public c'est
important de le rappeler par les îles
nourriture après simplement eric
naulleau seul vrai scandale
vestimentaires que j'ai vu dans le
football c'est que ribéry a débarqué en
claquettes au milieu en une émission de
télévision là il y avait vraiment un
scandale en brasse j'ai pas beaucoup
fréquenté les footballeurs mais je vois
qu'ils sont serait copains même avec les
rappeurs par exemple et ils ont un peu
tendance à adopter le même mode olivier
kachkach carbone je rejoins holy dis il
est trés il y très discret et très
discret griezmann filet très discret je
suis allé chez le austère il est très
discret après il a un bon look voilà
c'est tout c'est voilà cyril camu
mathieu c'est une sorte d mag et
d'inégalités sociales c'est comme ça
c'est pas autrement c'est malheureux
mais ça existe et semsales le monde ne
tournerait pas rond peut pas tous être
riche tout cette pauvre et ça faut
l'accepter malheureusement en
l'occurrence là les journalistes ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'ils ont décrit
comment était habillé les footballeurs
mais ce que les footballeurs se sont
montrés et ont montré sur les deux
surnoms
ils sont pas mis la marque ils ont pas
toutes à gué ils sont pas il s'habille
comme ça sur quoi s'est lui tendu ce
quartier est en train de perdre lui
montrer bfm je me défends mais je
défende pas le s'il l'achète je m'en
fous sur mon but j'ai fait c'est que ce
qu'est ce qu'ils ont voulu montrer ce
que pour vous le dans ce que vous dites
avoir de l'argent c'est réussir c'est
pas ça que réussir dans la vie c'était
forcément cyril vous avez tout à l'heure
vous avez tout à l'heure bah c'est
normal il faut rêver rêver les enfants
mais c'est un bon exemple pour vous pour
les enfants c'est un bel exemple l'art
est jolie j'ai envie d'être comme eux je
vais réussir peut-être toile à réussir
s'est pas passé dans mon argent cyril
réussir c'est sûr réaliser soi même
j'ai toujours syrie
après on aura mamie non ce que je sais
c'est que la lola c'est que les
journalistes ne font qu'attiser la haine
des gens c'est un genre de reportage
parce que sans ça je ne se poserait pas
sur la grande
alors il ya parce que quand ribéry mangé
un steak au nord avec une posture de
s'aggraver au plus haut on là ça
justement et franck ribéry il fait ce
qu'il veut mais puis désolé autres eh
ben il le monde parce que voilà il
voulait téléphoner c'est nerveux
s'arrêter si vous regardez la saga
restos c'est 1200 euros la pièce de
boeuf
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que tu ne manges ans mais non non mais
dans la vidéo il a pas de los teques
ville de soyaux on le sait mais pas du
tout non c'était marrant la vidéo avec
le maillot et on l'a prise pour lui il
est au menu du restaurant cias et le
second tube et isabelle morini-bosc je
suis plus le foot ne vous avez l'air de
le dire oui bien présent relativement et
pathé par la carrière de ribéry qui
s'est assagi café une bonne carrière
giroux et loris je les mets à part
maintenant je comprends ce que veut dire
qu'on prend ce que veut dire tu sais le
battle mathieu parce que effectivement
moi qui fait qu'ils aient de l'argent et
qu'ils achètent faut faire marcher le
commerce il faut bien que les gens qui
achètent des choses les très riches pour
les très riches en revanche qui m'embête
c'est que ça sent que cela s'accompagne
d'un comportement souvent bling-bling
machin est sourd relativement souvent
immatures et ça ça compte par deux
sorties à des moments improbables et
c'est que la valeur que sonne qu'ils
aient réussi qu ils méritent leur argent
oui qu'ils aient réussi puisque ce
soient des stars oui qu'ils soient très
bien mais parce qu'ils rapportent autant
wifi xiang commis encore une fois ce qui
est mon problème à moi c'est qui fait
qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils veulent qu'ils
le dépensent comme ils veulent
mais cette idée de vouloir le montre en
permanence alors que les gens alors et
je fais pas le truc mais effectivement
je passe parfois des très beaux arrêts
de bus et que j'aimerai bien sûr est ce
que tu me vois dans une belle voiture ou
dégageant qu'ils sont en phase de chaud
qui regardent et qui eux n'ont rien son
plan d appétit 2 je suis désolé je suis
un autre cyrille l'exemple qu'on doit
donner quand tu viens de dire que les
modèles les modèles aujourd'hui en
images sont des footballeurs mais tu
plaisantes ou des images à des histoires
de 2,2 par les merveilleux c'est que
sony
dire des bêtises tu fédéral à 68% à 32 %
il serait plutôt de votre côté
[Musique]